This question tests how well you understand the Diffie-Hellman key-agreement protocol.
The first two statements are the security of the scheme depends on it being difficult to solve
a^x = b mod n for a given b, n and x.
The security of the scheme depends on it being different to solve
a^x = b mod n for x given a, b, and n.
The last two statements are if the value used for g in the Diffie-Hellman scheme
is not a generator or a primitive root, the participants might not agree on the same key.
The last statement--if the modulus n is not prime, the Diffie-Hellman scheme
would still be correct, meaning two participants produce the same key,
but it might not be secure. Check all that apply.